roberto clemente day on the mariners
nominee kyle seeger walking the carpet
alongside a former award winner and of
course edgar martinez
marco gonzalez coming off two straight
starts against the arizona diamondbacks
coming off a six and in quality start
and he has really been fantastic
especially since the beginning of august
for the mariners now since the all-star
break a 1-6-3 era here at this home
ballpark 118 and a third 88 strikeouts
over 34 walks for marco
as he uh chops this to the wrong spot it
finds j.p crawford not where you want to
hit it if you're on the other side here
is honor renfro who's struggling all for
his last 11. seven strikeouts
this one's gonna be stroke that one high
and deep to left center that one is back
there back they're gone number 28 for
hunter renfro and a quick strike for the
red sox and he's been struggling lately
that's exactly what he needs to do get a
pitch up in the zone weight back sit
back because he's not coming in there
he's not breaking the speed limit so
excellent job getting the hands through
and a high fastball up in the zone
lofted into left field fraley in the
sunshine
two gun
chop back marco's got it easy play for
number seven tanner out on four 354 era
four losses eight no decisions no wins
yet for tanner
ground ball top to second throw to first
for the out he sort of tomahawk the high
pitch there
swings and drives one for the gap in
right center renfro goes over though and
makes the catch
two and two on seeger
and gets a ground ball again to the
right side bogarts will get him bobby
dalby get his 20-second home run last
night
swinging a high fly ball that one jack
to left fraley back on the track and not
gonna get it
and it's gonna take a bounce and go over
the wall
and fraley just butchered that he and
kelnick were staring at each other like
are you going to take it who's going to
take it so rbi situation for plucky
second and third one out
little poke to first base a runner is
going to score as he gets the out at
first and the red sox are up two to
nothing two nothing red sox glaciers up
he has five for his last nine
he's gonna hit this one into the gap and
that's gonna drop down for extra bases
another run is in to score iglesias
trots into second and the red sox lead
at three to nothing
swang and a miss look at the movement on
that
to collect his first k today
a little tapper
i'll go take that
two down
into the ship scooped up by iglesias one
hop on a standing play
swing and a miss
a wave and a miss chasing off the plate
back-to-back strikeouts
marco has it dialed in now he strikes
out the side and order
torrance goes down hacking that
strikeout number two for tanner there's
the murph tom murphy the catcher
there you go feud into right field
telnek on his way to third renfro with
the hose it skips away and in the camera
yes it does that brings kelnick home
and the mariners get their first run of
the day
runners now at second and third murphy
to third crawford to second that brings
up mitch haniger one man away
he'll rope that one and caught by xander
bogart's from the knees two ounce two on
for kyle seeger
inside the bag at fair murphy is in
crawford's coming home
kyle seeger into second base and he has
tied the game at three
swing and a miss at a fastball for
strike three that is strikeout number
four
chasing marco has it locked in now he
sat down seven in a row
three two
swing and a miss an unsure cut 95 miles
an hour to put away toro
called strike and fraley frozen
swing and a miss that's a fine inning
huh one two three he strikes them all
out
taking off again to throw the tag he's
safe
spikes iglesias in the process
kellen shaken up as well went in hard
kind of threw the play off
there's a good angle over there yep
big stolen base and now the mariners
will have runners on at first and third
with two down for kyle seeger looking
for the k on
seeger one hopper xander up and over
taylor continues to do good work
[Applause]
strike three call
big time strikeout
two gone marco will do it again
oh he got him
what a way to finish it for marco
gonzalez
he sits down 13 of the final 14 red sox
hitters he faces alex carr is going to
the bench alex verdugo to pinch it for
k.k hernandez here against the
right-hander sea wall first and third
time in the seventh two outs two on
and the left and the catch made by
fraley
long stretch runner holds
and a ground ball not hit really sharply
sideways flip onto first yes and that's
a beauty
on the ground flattens out for devers
who is with it high throw and hanniger
is safe
we will get anavino vs france
fastball and he struck him out swinging
[Applause]
hit him
just behind him scott service wants to
hold it up to him take a look at it but
instead he's going to take first base
yes he will
so the mariners have the winning run the
mariners have the winning run in scoring
position kellnick having a good
afternoon he is two for three and a
score to run
swag and a miss he struck him out first
and third nobody out it brings up renfro
who homered in the first here's the
pitch and a high off the mid of the
catcher goes to the backstop and lopez
scores to go head run
gonna knock that one in the center field
coming on calendar coming on can't get
there drops in for a base hit runners
had to hold so the bases are going to be
loaded and they are filled up with
nobody out rafael devers about the
swings
on the ground france coming home with it
they get the lead man at home plate
verdugo faces still loaded one out now
jd martinez right hand
hitter bounding ball off the glove one
run is in
the red sox lead it five to three on a
base hit one out still bases lower here
for schwaber
shot into right field of base hit he's
struck again
bogarts is in
here comes denver's safe at the plate he
did it again unbelievable and the red
sox have a four run laid they're loaded
up once again and here's vasquez who
struck out as a pinch hitter against
castello in the ninth they lead all the
way around the one-two
little flare and that is gonna be a fair
ball
red sox continue to strike one big hit
after another two more in
he's all the way down to second red sox
laid it nine three a chalk ball it
looked like
one two struck him out and the red sox
win it